hey good morning to you a lot of new
information to report to you this
morning because in the last 24 hours
we visited a hospital and heard
remarkable news stories of survival
we've also talked to police and the
Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco Firearms and
Explosives and this morning we know
important new details about how and
where Stephen paddock got his weapons
this is what we know
he bought nearly 50 guns legally the ATF
tells me he purchased 33 firearms in the
last year alone a majority of them are
rifles the ATF said none of the
purchases set off any red flags we're
also getting our first look inside the
hotel suite where paddock orchestrated
his massacre now while his motive
remains a mystery it is clear he was
armed for an even longer siege this
police body cam video shows the
relentless firepower were up against
Sunday night for up to 11 minutes
Steven paddock shot concert goers with
seemingly endless bursts of gunfire over
a dozen volleys in all he had been
stockpiling his firearms since 1982
according to Jill Snyder a special agent
in charge at the Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms
how many firearms were purchased in the
last year from October 2016 to September
28th 2017 he purchased 33 firearms
majority of them rifles that didn't set
off a red flag anywhere in the ATF we
wouldn't get notified of the purchases
of the rifles we would only get notified
if there was a multiple sale which would
be two or more handguns in an individual
purchase
why is there no notification if
someone is buying multiple rifles
there's no federal law requiring that
Schneider revealed to us that paddock
rigged 12 semi-automatic rifles with
bump fire stocks the devices allowed the
guns to fire continuously much like an
automatic weapon a semi-automatic rifle
with a bump fire stock on it is not is
not a illegal machine gun how big were
the ammo clips the ammo clip capacities
range from 60 rounds to 100 rounds so he
had huge clips of ammunition yes
CBS News has learned paddock also set up
cameras in and around the luxury suite
he turned into a sniper's nest a kind of
early warning system for any approaching
police officers as he fired out of two
windows one camera peered out the Suites
peephole two more cameras were in the
hallway outside one of them was on a
room service cart outside the door says
Las Vegas Metro PD Sheriff Joe Lombardo
was the gunman recording was the gunman
transmitting that video anywhere else
I'm not aware of any transmission but
there was cameras and he had set up how
many cameras for what purpose do you
think well I anticipate he was looking
for anybody coming to take them into
custody so essentially you have a
recording of him carrying out this
carnage no that's not essentially what
I'm saying that is being evaluated the
FBI took all digital and electronic
evidence into custody and we are
evaluating so there you see there's a
lot of electronic evidence that they are
going to be evaluating as the sheriff
told me also this we've learned from the
ATF that Steven paddock bought a gun or
perhaps guns as late as Thursday that is
three days before he carried out this
attack right behind me bottom line we
learned yesterday is that you can buy as
many semi-automatic weapons as you want
and the ATF tells us they wouldn't know
about it because there's no federal law
requiring a licensed gun dealer to
report that Jill Snyder of the ATF also
told us they have agents looking into
whether paddock was spending time at
area
gun rages today they're also expected to
release new information the ATF says
perhaps the entire list of what those
guns were those 47 guns that have been
that have been brought up quired by the
ATF and FBI Gail Charlie bianna we will
have more from North throughout this
evening throughout the morning